نعم لا شك انه بمقدور الامم المتحده فيما
لو وصلت تلك المساعدات ان تصل الى شمال
غرب سوريا
بالتوقيت ذاته علينا ان ننوه الى ان هذه
الكوارث التي تحصل او الكارثه التي حصلت
بموجب الزلزال هي كارثه لا يمكن التحكم
بها لكن هنالك كوارث اخرى من الممكن
التحكم بها يعني منذ يومين والنظام السوري
قصف مدينه مارع ومن ثم قبل قليل اخبار احد
الاصدقاء بانه قد قصف ريف حماه وبالتالي
نحن نتحدث عن ماساه مركبه الاصل فيها هو
انهاء مساله الملف السياسي والا ستبقى
الكوارث تدريجيا يعني تتنقل بين الفينه
والاخرى وبالتالي اذا ما اخذنا مع
الاعتبار في حال اوصلت الامم المتحده تلك
المساعدات فالطريق الدولي اذا كان عبر
جسرا جويا اعتقد بانه متاح اذا اخذ بان
الاعتبار سيكون
يعمل بشكل كامل ربما في هذه الليله وغدا
صباحا ومن ثم من مطار هاتاي الى معبر باب
الهواء الطريق الدولي ايضا يعمل وان كان
هنالك صعوبات في بعض المناطق التي فيها
لكن عمليا هو ما زال يعمل بشكل انسيابي
كامل وكثير امكانيه باعتقادك لفتح بقيه
المعابر او معابر اخرى على الاقل مثل
الذين تحدث عنهما تشاوش اوغلو اليوم او
امس هنالك نعم هنالك مع باب السلامه وايضا
هناك جرابلس وكذلك ايضا معبر اخر ثالث من
الممكن ان يتم فتحه في حال تم اصلاح طرق
الدوليه انا اتحدث الطرق الدوليه المؤديه
الى تلك المعابر هنالك حدثت اضرار كبيره
سواء كان من مدينه عنتاب او حتى من مدن
اخرى المطله على هذه المعابره